kosmische radio blitze
blitzlichtgewitter aus dem all
sensationell port scholz von der mcgill
university hat mehrere
aufeinanderfolgende radio blitze
entdeckt das wirft alle bisherigen
erkenntnisse mächtig durcheinander
kosmische radio blitze die werden fasst
the byrds genannt kurz fab sind starke
puls im bereich der radiowellen die
biker clubs mischen ereignissen für ein
paar wenige millisekunden entstehen
unter kataklysmus versteht man übrigens
katastrophale ereignisse und wer das im
zusammenhang mit dem weltraum steht geht
es dabei um sachen wie supernovae oder
kometen anschläge bisher konnte man rund
20 dieser fps entdecken den ersten sogar
erst 2007
bislang hat man in der wissenschaft
angenommen diese blitze würden nur
einzeln auftreten
das dachte man zumindest bis vor kurzem
paul scholz konnte jetzt in den daten
des arecibo radioteleskops in puerto
rico außergewöhnliches beobachten
im november 2012 in den gemachten
aufnahmen damals entdeckte er ganze 10
in reihe aufblitzende fast railbirds
zitat diese wiederholten signale waren
überraschend und sehr aufregend ich
wusste sofort dass diese entdeckung für
die erforschung der schnellen radio
pulse enorm wichtig ist so paul scholz
das was scholz da entdeckt hatte dürfte
es einige astronomen nach gar nicht
geben
die katag lyss mission ereignisse die
man als ursache für die lvb
verantwortlich gemacht hatte
zeichneten sich bisher dadurch aus dass
etwas zerstört wird und was zerstört
wird das existiert danach nun mal nicht
mehr ist er kaputt ein blitz könne also
demnach nur einmal entstehen die reihe
von aufeinanderfolgenden radio blitzen
stellt die ursprungs erklärung also
erstmal in frage
die wissenschaftler dazu zitat
wiederholte radio pulse schließen
erklärungsmodelle mit kataklysmus
ereignissen wie chef schmelzenden oder
kollabierenden neutronenstern aus zitat
ende
diese feststellung kommt jetzt äußerst
überraschend denn von noch nicht einmal
einem jahr dachte man dass man dem
phänomen fvb entscheidend näher gekommen
sei im april 2015 gelang es
australischen forschern mit dem box
radioteleskop einen abbey life auf
zeichnen bis daher wurden radio blitz
immer nur auf eltern aufzeichnungen
gefunden
das zurückverfolgen zur quelle war dann
einfach nicht möglich am 18 april 2015
aber konnten die wissenschaftler einen
galaxie in circa 6 milliarden
lichtjahren entfernung als ausgangspunkt
des radio places ausmachen
das war ihn mit hilfe des nachglühen es
gelungen zitat es ist das erste mal dass
wir die heimat galaxie eines fast ray
burst bestimmen konnten schrieb even
jane fonda square kilometer r
organisation damals im fachmagazin
nature
als ursache für den blitz machten sie
einen gamma blitz aus man ist damit nur
einem einzelnen radio blitz näher
gekommen der nicht das ganze phänomen
radio blitz erklären kann zu diesem
zeitpunkt wusste man noch nicht dass
auch sich wiederholende radio blitze
existieren auch gibt es kritische
stimmen die an der interpretation der
daten zweifeln genauer ob die
radiowellen des nachglühen es wirklich
aus diesen quellen stammen oder
vielleicht sich möglicherweise von radio
quellen anderen ursprungs verändert
wurden so dass die bestimmung der
galaxie falsch sein könnte
aber zurück zu den sich wiederholenden
blitzen woher kommen diese repetitiven
signale experten des
max-planck-instituts für radioastronomie
in bonn zufolge könnten die blitze von
einem extragalaktischen neutronenstern
ausgegangen sein dieser könnte ein so
starkes magnetfeld haben dass es bei
seiner rotation und zu wechselwirkungen
kommen kann und daher immer wieder
strahlung im radiowellenbereich
abschicken wurde zitat es ist eine
aufregende zeit für die erforschung der
schnellen radio pulse mit fast jeder
neuen quelle lernen wir etwas neues sagt
jason hessels von der universität
amsterdam die erforschung unseres
weltraums bleibt spannend es gibt immer
wieder etwas neues zu entdecken nicht
vergessen den daumen hoch wenn euch das
video gefallen hat kostenlos abonnieren
also den abo button anklicken und was
glaubt ihr was würden die menschen tun
wenn sie keine rätsel keine phänomene
mehr erforschen konnten
es gibt so viele dinge die wir noch
nicht erklären können aber wie wäre es
wenn wir wirklich
einfach alles schon wissen lasst uns
darüber mal in den kommentaren
diskutieren und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran